there's obviously some controversial
like things that happen in the game you
know it's rough in the pastor not only
the roughing the pastor call on Chris
Jones
um but you know the roughing the
capacity call on uh on Tom Brady and uh
Grady Jarrett yeah two like both of
those was crazy what do you what do you
think about though I mean specifically
this year you've seen a lot of guys like
push a guy or shove a guy you barely
really hit him you feel like in the past
that would have never been a call but
they've been kind of throwing a trying
to protect the quarterbacks a lot this
year being I don't know how big Chris
Jones is dude I imagine he's close to
300 pounds yeah he kind of breaks
himself too he's trying to like try to
keep him he tried to keep him from
Landing right on top of him while he's
trying to take the ball from him it's a
lot to ask from uh Dylan even though
Chris is crazy athletic like he trying
to strip the ball he try not to land on
somebody that's a lot to ask for
somebody playing football in general